koné monte sur mon dos non à numéros le
procès civil était pas dans le before
c'est vrai que christophe nous a dit
j'adore la cambrure de nadège surtout
qu'on pourrait presque y poser un verre
elle nous a dit quelqu'un déjà poser un
verre quand je me mets comme ceux ci on
pourrait poser un jerrican c'est pas un
verre alors qu'est ce que on annonce des
choses sachant que si le père ne tient
pas il se renversera sur une auréole sur
les fesses pendant toute l'émission de
ça mais ça ferait du français attention
positionné il est sobre ne bougeait pas
au bout ça maintenant car c'est le grand
cabaret que nous faisons ce soir va
récupérer le versant les mains et le
boire et attends je regardais ce numéro
regardez regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
christophe ça va bouger bien christophe
gay très rapidement sort un livre
aujourd'hui voilà donc eh oui bah on va
passer très rapidement dessus clé sauf
carrière parce que ça s'appelle c'est
pas grave ça va pas durer
jeudi son éditeur et il a signé le
contrat voilà et d'ailleurs pour assurer
la promotion christophe véla vous allez
maintenant faire le tour du plateau avec
le livre sur la tête sans qu'il faut
voir les numéros
il va pas tomber nous avons eu droit de
12,2 à la promo qui le sont pas
[Applaudissements]
voilà le belle histoire d'amour dans la
dernière
[Applaudissements]
monter sur mon dos tient à numéros
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
nous allons faire le vieux chalet le
vieux-hull et lemieux janin vous restez
immobile et puis j'ai le droit de dormir
de toute façon c'est un peu ce que vous
faites attention vous ne bougez plus
vous dormez et là vous essayez d'en
empiler non mais oh là là encore quand
même on n'est pas censé pour le
réveiller rihanna il y en a deux noms
mais il y en a trois sinon je fais un
côté fêtés à côté c'est chaque plat et
mettez lui sur son gros qui nous et il y
en a trois ça marche pas très bien votre
estomac mais c'est super dur c'est pour
ça que d'ailleurs ceux qui ont été
sélectionnés symptômes ne bougeait plus
ah oui car c'est vous alors
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]